[Musique]
ce jeudi 8 juin le département de La
Réunion et France volontaire ont signé
une convention de partenariat pour la
mise en oeuvre du projet de la
collectivité dans le domaine du
volontariat
par cette convention syntagre dans un
programme qui s'appelle territoire
volontaire l'idée c'est d'accompagner
des collectivités territoriales qui le
souhaitent dans leur projet
international parce que on est convaincu
que le volontariat international
d'échanges et de solidarité permet à la
fois d'accompagner les jeunesses dans
leur insertion en leur donnant des
compétences on en permettant
d'expérimenter l'étranger mais c'est
aussi un moyen pour une collectivité de
travailler sur l'action internationale
la coopération des centralisée dans des
coopérations avec des partenaires dans
les pays particulièrement ici à l'océan
Indien cette convention c'est le moyen
pour le département et France volontaire
de mettre en oeuvre 13 missions de
volontariat dans le cadre de ce
programme territoire volontaire
une convention qui s'inscrit dans les
priorités au titre de la coopération
régionale mise en place dans le plan de
mandature
2021-2028 c'est que les jeunes en fait
puissent se trouver vraiment une
ouverture d'esprit et comprendre la
capacité que c'est de de pouvoir être
accompagné être rassuré de pas avoir
peur de se lancer et pas avoir peur
aussi de se dire que je ne sais pas ce
que je vais découvrir mais je vais y
aller quand même parce que je suis très
bien accompagné et à la fin on est ravi
de voir que les jeunes arrivent à se
trouver à trouver une volonté une
profession même et une orientation pour
leur avenir
des contrats qui pour les jeunes
représentent une vraie opportunité et un
enrichissement personnel
les cultures je suis tombée sur une
annonce pour un service civique à
l'international c'était de base
en Afrique du Sud et pour une mission de
je crois que c'était secrétaire pour une
alliance Française j'ai passé un
entretien et par rapport à mes
compétences on m'a mis sur un poste de
chargé de communication ce qui était
super ça allait totalement avec mon
profil et ce que j'avais appris donc je
suis partie et j'ai saisi cette
opportunité par curiosité et pas envie
de redonner du sens à ce que j'avais
fait auparavant et me prouver que je
savais faire des choses donc prendre
confiance en moi du coup j'ai été envoyé
pour valoriser les échanges valoriser et
développer les échanges qui existaient
entre la Réunion et le sud-ouest de
Madagascar
ça m'a donné envie de continuer dans ce
domaine en fait du coup je savais pas où
j'étais ce que je voulais et ben j'ai
trouvé je vais bosser dans la
coopération internationale du coup j'ai
continué avec l'ONG pendant deux ans
encore donc au total trois ans et après
je suis rentré et là je suis en
formation de langue pour pouvoir à bac +
3 reprendre de nouveau une formation de
logistique humanitaire ou gestion de
projet pour le département la mobilité
internationale des jeunes favorise leur
insertion sociale et professionnelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]